Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
soy lluis Muñoz y en esta edición
conversamos con Pablo Iglesias ex
vicepresidente del gobierno de España y
fundador de podemos partido político de
izquierda que irrumpió en 2014 Y
actualmente es parte del gobierno este
año Pablo Iglesias ha publicado verdades
a la cara con editorial navona y se
espera que llegue a América Latina en
2023 un testimonio escrito junto al
periodista aitor Ribeiro después de
retirarse de la política en 2021 el
libro como bien indica su nombre
verdades a la cara se convierte en un
grito contra el poder y la política
Pablo fue un proceso catártico es un
libro cuya elaboración es extraña y
no se parece a lo que suelen ser los
libros de memoria yo no quería escribir
un libro de memorias y cuando Ernest
folch yabaomerrow es me propusieron
hacer este libro lo que les plante es yo
estoy dispuesto a que me hagan una
entrevista larga no a concebir un libro
de memorias y una suerte de ajuste de
cuentas entonces accedieron a esta
exigencia mía y después a la hora de
buscar un periodista que quisiera hacer
esto
aito riveiro es alguien que conoce muy
bien
Podemos y la historia de podemos y fue
muy hábil en las sesiones que tuvimos
crear mis sesiones de varias horas los
viernes aitor fue capaz de tirarme de la
lengua y como explico en algún lugar del
Libro de sentarme en el diván y por
tanto el libro tiene muchos elementos de
pura espontaneidad de respuestas muy
rápidas a las cuestiones que le
preguntaba eso no quiere decir que no
estuvieran muy medi estaban meditadas a
lo largo de los años pero no la manera
Digamos como de exponerlas yo creo que
esto le da al libro una frescura y una
autenticidad que es lo que está haciendo
que funcione en los comentarios que me
llegan los lectores es que es un libro
muy fácil de leer precisamente por eso
por por la espontaneidad y una cierta
frescura que tiene que ver mucho más con
el trabajo de editor que con el mío
estuvo en la primera línea de la
política durante siete años y fue parte
del gobierno e incluso los sondeos le
colocaron presidenciable qué faltó para
que Pablo Iglesias llegase a convertirse
en presidente del gobierno de España
un cúmulo de factores yo creo que a mí
no me hubieran dejado ser presidente
nunca incluso Aunque podemos hubiera
sido la fuerza más votada en unas
elecciones generales estuvo a punto de
serlo de hecho lo fue como decías en
Cataluña en euskadi fuimos la fuerza
política de la izquierda también en la
comunidad de Madrid en la comunidad
valenciana en baleares en Canarias
creo que incluso Si se hubiera dado ese
tipo de correlación el partido
socialista nunca habría aceptado
gobernar en coalición con podemos y
mucho menos que yo hubiera sido
presidente del gobierno pues esto Ahora
lo tengo clarísimo lo sospechaba
entonces pero ahora lo tengo muy claro
creo que una de las claves para entender
el declive electoral de podemos no la
única pero sí la más importante y la que
menos se ha atendido es que podemos
junto al independentismo Catalán provocó
que se desencadenara un movimiento
reaccionario desde el poder desde los
aparatos del estado y los poderes
mediáticos
en nuestro país el estado ya había
renunciado a su propia legalidad para
combatir el terrorismo de eta y para
combatir también el desafío
independentista pero renunció a su
propia legalidad para combatirnos a
nosotros y en ese caso eso tuvo su
expresión más evidente en el actor
ideológico más importante en las
sociedades mediatizadas o en las
mediocracias que vivimos que son los
poderes mediáticos la tarea de desgaste
contra Nuestra fuerza política y contra
sus principales dirigentes ha sido algo
absolutamente
escandaloso y definitorio de la
corrupción en la democracia española
podemos aparece después del 15m en 2011
y tras tres huelgas generales en tres
años podemos decir que podemos canalizar
la rabia de las calles y si fue así
piensa usted que pudo favorecer eso a
los poderes tradicionales
diría que todo lo contrario mientras no
pasamos a la institución
lo que nosotros representamos no era un
gran problema
en el movimiento 15m las huelgas
generales
la plataforma de afectados por la
hipoteca los movimientos sociales que de
alguna manera estaban vinculando la
violencia social de la crisis que está
ya en el año 2008 implicó una serie de
transformaciones en la estructura
ideológica de la sociedad
yo creo que eso tardó en hacerse visible
y mucho más en hacerse presente en lo
electoral Pero empezó a notarse en lo
mediático los discursos que de alguna
manera trasladaban esa transformación en
la estructura ideológica de la sociedad
tenían más audiencia Ese es el fenómeno
Pablo Iglesias del año 2013 y 2014 en
las televisiones Y eso es lo que nos
permite un Blitz electoral una erupción
electoral en las elecciones europeas a
partir de ahí ya no solamente éramos la
expresión de un humor social determinado
a partir de entonces éramos una
alternativa de gobierno éramos una
fuerza política que podía cambiar cosas
desde las instituciones eso es lo que
los poderes no aceptaron en ningún caso
y eso es lo que reveló Hasta qué punto
nuestra democracia es un sistema de
democracia limitada limitada por los
poderes mediáticos limitada por amplios
sectores del poder judicial limitada por
sectores muy importantes del estado creo
que podemos ha
para arrojar luz sobre la verdadera
naturaleza institucional de nuestro
estado y de sus profundas carencias
democráticas en el libro insiste en la
latinoamericanización de la derecha en
España y viendo el mapa actual de
gobiernos de América Latina piensa usted
que la izquierda Española y la europea
también necesitan latinoamericanizarse
Bueno lo que se decía con podemos es que
podemos ir a latinoamericanizar la
política Española y lo que ha ocurrido
es que ha sido precisamente la
ultraderecha y la derecha
latinoamericana la que ha sido capaz en
un contexto de éxito de Donald Trump y
de ultraderer hechizos de un creciente
de las derechas mundiales de trasladar
sus estilos acá estilos enormemente
agresivos de normalización abierta de la
mentira y no es menos cierto que a día
de hoy el único territorio donde fuerzas
políticas izquierdas ganan elecciones y
gobiernan y son capaces de implementar
algunos cambios es América Latina pero
ojo hay un límite fundamental las
grandes oposiciones a los gobiernos de
izquierdas en América Latina no son los
partidos de la derecha latinoamericana
es la derecha mediática latinoamericana
últimamente
[Música]
mucha atención a chile y creo que el
último plebiscito sobre sobre el
proyecto de nueva constitución revela
que el gran actor político contrario al
gobierno que fue contrario a su vez a la
Constitución que tuvieron que votar los
chilenos el 4 de septiembre era
básicamente la derecha mediática y esos
estilos mediáticos de la derecha hemos
visto que aquí se están normalizando por
completo la farandurización de los
programas de debate político el
despliegue de mentiras de enorme
eficacia ideológica independientemente
de que de que se puedan desmontar
después y eso es algo normalmente
peligroso para la democracia hablando de
América Latina como Colombia ha podido
tener su primer gobierno de izquierda de
la historia y chile ha podido volver a
tener un gobierno de izquierda
en los dos casos hay un elemento muy
similar que es un apellido social como
consecuencia del colapso de y el fracaso
de las políticas neoliberales eso
produce situaciones de quiebra de
determinados consensos sociales y Abre
estructuras de oportunidad que pueden
tener traducciones electorales en
contextos muy diferentes como en este
caso el colombiano y el chileno
los estallidos sociales pueden tener una
traducción electoral El problema es que
si no se produce también una
transformación en la estructura
ideológica de las sociedades los cambios
pueden ser muy difícil que haya habido
un estallido social en chile y en
Colombia que haya permitido ganar las
elecciones a candidatos de izquierdas no
quiere decir que las sociedades
colombianas y chilenas se hayan hecho
más de izquierdas quiere decir que ese
colapso ha tenido una traducción
política en un momento coyuntural
determinado pero lo fundamental en la
política es la batalla ideológica que
reparte a partir de ahí y ahí quien
mejor preparado está siempre es que
encuentra con quien cuenta con
dispositivos ideológicos para esa
batalla que son fundamentalmente los
medios de comunicación pero también las
instituciones educativas también las
editoriales todos los aparatos de tipo
cultural e ideológico que
definen en última instancia la ideología
de una sociedad habla en el libro de que
para tras el capitalismo hace falta un
desafío militar global pero la guerra en
Ucrania y las crisis que se diadivan hay
espacio para esa transición a lo que me
refería con eso es a que
una política que desafíe la lógica de la
acumulación capitalista no se puede dar
en la escala estatal en la escala de los
estados nación tradicionales porque el
capitalismo funciona a escala planetaria
estamos viendo además que la propia
Guerra de Ucrania responde a un
enfrentamiento geopolítico entre la
potencia cuya hegemonía está en
decadencia los Estados Unidos y el
hegemon emergente que sería en este caso
chino creo que hay temas fundamentales
de la política que solamente se pueden
dar en lo que los teóricos del análisis
de sistemas mundo llamaban escala de la
realidad la escala de la economía mundo
la escala mundial si esos desafíos no se
asumen yo creo que los peligros para la
humanidad en términos de continuidad de
la propia especie humana son enormes y
están ahí parece increíble que estemos
hablando de esto pero es que a la
situación tanto por lo que la
posibilidad de que la guerra escale a un
escenario nuclear como la propia finitud
del planeta la crisis energética
alimentaria etcétera nos colocan en un
lugar enormemente peligroso en su texto
también se siente una preocupación al
auge de la ultraderecha habla del poco
valor de la democracia en países como
Hungría o Polonia y el contexto limita a
la izquierda simplemente a un eje de
democracia contra autoritarismo Bueno es
un clásico del siglo 20 la izquierda o
los comunistas defendiendo la democracia
liberal Es verdad que estamos en un
contexto en el que la izquierda defiende
básicamente programas socialdemócratas
viables en el marco de la economía de
mercado porque la correlación de fuerzas
no permite otra cosa al tiempo que la
ultraderetización de las fuerzas
conservadoras yo creo que amenaza
claramente la propia forma lateral de la
Democracia que se había planteado como
una suerte de fin de la historia yo creo
que la izquierda no debe renunciar a dar
al mismo tiempo desde el pragmatismo
programático de las políticas públicas
que son posibles desde dispositivos
institucionales a dar una pelea
ideológica que señale que el capitalismo
es un sistema histórico que debe ser
superado en aras de la Democracia de la
dignidad y de los derechos de la
humanidad creo que eso es fundamental y
para acabar tras pasar por el gobierno
no es un poco frustrante no poder
realizar grandes transformaciones Bueno
ya lo sabíamos nosotros sabíamos que
tener el gobierno no es tener el poder y
no digamos ser el socio minoritario en
una coalición de gobierno Pero es verdad
que la experiencia de vivirlo pues dará
muchas tablas y es verdad que en algunos
momentos puede producir amargura
pero yo estoy feliz de poder hacer
política desde donde el agua ahora como
podcaster como comentarista y como
analista y muy contento también de haber
vivido una serie de experiencias como
dirigente político que me han dado una
serie de tablas que no se pueden
adquirir en otro lugar y en otro tipo de
experiencias Entonces Bueno pues con
con la mirada con tonalidades grises de
lo que de lo que implica analizar
fríamente la realidad pero al mismo
tiempo con optimismo de la voluntad y
muy contento de las cosas que hago
Muchas gracias Pablo Iglesias por estar
en France 24 y muchas gracias También a
nuestra audiencia Pueden seguir más
contenidos como este en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]